hier à 13 heures tous les yeux étaient
rivés sur la rentrée des jt de tf1 et
france 2 il faut dire que ces deux
carrefour de l'info sont très suivis par
les français et que pour la première
fois depuis 33 ans les deux programmes
voyait en même temps leurs présentateurs
changé bonjour est très heureuse de vous
accompagner à partir d'aujourd'hui
bonjour à tous ravis de me retrouver
c'est un immense plaisir de vous
accompagner désormais ce matin à 9
heures précises le couperet est tombé
marie sophie lacarrau a gagné son pari
pour cette première en réunissant 6,4
millions de téléspectateurs devant le
13h de tf1 animé depuis trois décennies
par jean pierre pernaut belle audience
qui a forcément fait des dégâts du côté
de france 2 juillan budget qui est
aujourd'hui le nouveau visage de l'info
de france télévisions a dû quant à lui
se contenter de 3 millions de
téléspectateurs une audience moitié
inférieure à celle de sa principale
concurrente
c'est évidemment la douche froide même
si c'est une bonne audience pour france
2 à cette heure-ci difficile d'imaginer
comment les cours pourraient s'inverser
rapidement pour delà de jean pierre
pernaut et de sa grande popularité
le jt de 13h de tf1 semble avoir réussi
à fidéliser durablement ses
téléspectateurs toujours bon de leur
rappeler de plus on a appris hier que
marie sophie lacarrau serait mieux payés
sur tf1 que sur france 2 l'occasion pour
nous de vous révéler tous les salaires
des présentateurs de journaux télévisés
alors combien sont ils payés
et oui les salaires des présentateurs de
journaux télévisés alors anne marie
sophie lacarrau qui a réussi son entrée
un car trop ce qu'on pensait que ça va
se maintenir nicolas permis alors non je
pense pas que ça va se maintenir je
pense qu'il ya eu un effet curiosité
forcément vous savez qu'en ce moment
avec le co vide il ya quasiment un
million huit cent mille téléspectateurs
en plus et ça regarde les journaux à
13h14 que je pense c'est julian bugier
est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de talent
mahmoudi un mec authentique sincère qui
parle aux français et à mon avis d'ici
quinze jours trois semaines il peut
créer la surprise 3 millions c'est un
très bon démarrage
il peut monter un droit mais loin que
marie sophie lacarrau l'année dernière
c'est un petit peu moins de trois
millions trois millions et demi
rapidement et vous pouvez vous retrouver
avec 3 4 points 2 - de côté de tf1 et
34.8 plus du côté de france 2 qui serait
logique alors marie sophie lacarrau elle
a fait une petite sortie elle a dit
qu'elle était beaucoup mieux payés sur
tf1 que sur france 2 nicolas pernikoff
est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire vous
qui étiez on est dans les arcanes bien
entendu du pouvoir et de france et ils
ont gagné un garçon qui fait le jt de
france 2 à 13 heures moi je pense qu'il
y ait entre temps entouré de dix douze
mille euros 10 2010 quatre années qui
connaît un peu bien jaugé les salaires
et au dj
france télévisions france télévisions la
bri à bâle aurait dit mais le dit minoru
et ses 12000 euros par mois bravo
nicolas pernikoff 12000 euros par mois
en tout cas merci d'être là
isabelle morini bosc qui se croient
juste pris quinze jours tyrolien dans un
instant laurent delahousse y gagne un
petit peu plus celui gagné quinze mille
euros par mois mais voilà laurent
delahousse david pujadas 18000 euros par
mois que laurent et enfin ce producteur
et oui bel et bien je parle tout le
temps uniquement sur l'été de 18000
euros pas mois par pour david pujadas
sur france 3 que vous savez combien
c'est sur france 3 ah c'est beaucoup
moins six mois c'est combien dois à mon
avis c'est plutôt autour des 5 que 5,6
nos 6000 euros bravo nicolas pernikoff
pour un présentateur du jt de france 3
pour m6 no 19 45 est atteint 1000 ça ne
s'appelait pas venu et ça me plaît pas
et sur tf1 alors ne les mettez pas tout
de suite
bah oui on réagit toujours les génies
bien entendu anne claire coudray a gagné
environ 30000 euros par mois le week-end
ouais c'est ça mais c'est beaucoup moins
que chazal à l'époque 100 mille euros
ouais ouais c'est ça aussi c'était moi
pas plus que ça non soit champion de 8
ans avançaient que tu as en face à elle
gagné 120 milles à raison monde benjamin
castaldi et gilles bouleau pour la
quotidienne le soir vous avez 50
maintenant 35 90 euros par mois ce sont
environ 1600 euros par jt et les stars
voilà voilà la jeune star voilà comme
jean pierre pernaut et d'autres c'est au
tour de 60000 euros un sas à laurence
ferrari à l'époque donc marie sophie
laloy trois ans d'ancienneté pendant
exactement marie sophie lacarrau je
pense à elle doit elle d'aujourd'hui à
mon avis 12 millions sur des airs de la
douche transmise au tour de france son
salaire avait donc c'est vrai que c'est
incroyable quand elle dit qu'elle est
beaucoup mieux payés à tf1 car la france
ne laisseront pas par rapport aux
animateurs qui fera un prime sur tf1
peuvent toucher envoyé de près de 20000
euros hors taxes on va dire quinze mille
euros de mouthe wedge antilles moi je
chante et je vous dis la vérité parce
qu'on est là vous donner des chiffres un
peu bas
animateur sur tf1 pour un prime il prend
trente mille euros à mon époque je
pensais à baisser un peu je pense que
vous pensez vous que j'en compte remplir
ses 30000 euros aurait pas dû partir ses
30000 euros surfant en facturant fin
quand même c'est énormément énormément
la série dans ses effectifs
juste un truc qu'il faut savoir sur le
service public c'est que vous avez une
personne qui s'appelle un contrôleur
d'état qui n'est pas être ministère et
vous ne pouvez pas gagner ce que vous
voulez vous ne pouvez pas donner ce que
vous voulez soit un collaborateur de
france division amateur soit un
journaliste est encadré donc ça passe
par le contrôleur d'état ce qui explique
que les gens gagnent beaucoup moins
d'argent mais quand on vient sur le
service public en général on viendra
pour là c'est pareil pour france inter
pour les animals soyouz aura lautner lit
ça n'a rien à voir avec les salaires qui
ne pas voir sur rtl
outre europe à rouiba alors il me semble
me connaît qu'à une époque il y avait
des contrats hors cadre à france
télévisions ok mais il y avait ce qu'ont
engagée en dehors de la grille et qui
était payé beaucoup plus 7 est mis en
cause par elkabbach à l'époque et
notamment jean pierre sueur a pas de
grille fixé négociations en fonction
d'un notoriété si jean pierre pernaut
avait décidé de passer sur france 2
évidemment qu'ils auraient ils
risqueraient de casser la grille de sa
pensée j'aurais aussi l avis des autres
journalistes et à protéger si on dit
quelque chose il 4 julien courbet je
sais pas si vous souhaitez
il est venu l'autre on n'en a pas parlé
en cours mais qu'il est assis sur son
lit était massée sur france télévisions
et la grande galère pour julien quand il
était passé sur france télé sur une
quotidienne je crois c'est en tout
l'actrice huit ou dix neuf exactement 18
heures sur sur france 2 on se savait
était conduite par nagui puisqu'il était
hors de question à l'époque vous aviez
christine albanel en souvient qui était
ministre de la culture qui avait
contrôlé le contrat qu'elle a elle mis
en place avec julien courbet qui a qui
arrivent et des chaînes privées ce qui
avait fait un scandale je me rabats de
nicolas sarkozy qui était président à
l'époque il avait dit france télévisions
ils ont engagé courbet attention à
l'animateur un pas le sculpteur je vous
le jure que c'est vrai c'est nicolas
sarkozy qu'avec cette battue casse avait
fait un scandale mais le privé sur le
brésil
sur les animateurs ça peut se discuter
encore on confond toujours les deux mais
sur les journalistes effectivement tu as
raison il ya une grille salariale
impossible et un syndicat qui veille et
un contrôleur d'état effectivement ça
n'est pas possible et c'est logique
d'ailleurs que les chaînes privées
soient plus libres de leurs salaires que
les chaînes publiques avec une redevance
c'est une cervelle dans la logique des
choses et sur tf1 il ya souvent ils sont
patrons de leur journal donc ils sont
rémunérés en plus ils sont rédaction
possible la gueule alors soutiennent
qu'ils étaient sur tf1 combien vous
aviez pont après une faute sur tf1 mise
à part tous qu'ils aient eu une vmc qui
vous paye en deux temps d'abord des
raccords c'est plus après le plat et des
bons usages non 15000 euros
moi j'étais en francs à l'époque non non
non c'est un pari c'est un sesterce a
laissé faire et bien mariés 15000 euros
web vidéo gag vous étiez payer comme l'a
dit non alors vidéo gag en france tu
payes et déjà pour cette merde de 10
millions téléspectateurs n'ont alors le
précédent maire de l'époque avec trois
chaînes un oui mais à l'époque il y
avait et avait eu déjà un chien qui pète
ou bien sur france 2 avait toujours des
traces apostrophe combat c'était sympa
posteront mais bon match à tous et sur
france 3 j'ai jamais eu des trucs alors
vous vous étiez pour mon nom alors à peu
près à peu près comment tourner et vous
savez c'est seydou chinois sur tf1 par
mois je sais pas on attend les 150000
euros
quoi par 150 me moi moi c'est à moi
j'avais dit aux gars que j'avais la une
est à vous non j'avais plein de spécial
et spécialement
je me demande je vais de police et 150
mille fonction sa copine aux 750
millions d'euros et il a ses fils assis
là bas j'ai vraiment retiennent enfants
des parents et en france oui mais là il
a converti vous souvenez quand même que
la une est à bout c'était le rendez vous
un peu du vivement dimanche et michel
herbert était le rendez vous
incontournable de l'été mais marco des
chats vous a pas demandé de défendre son
salaire n'ont pas de salaire mais parce
que la vraie info non mais faut qu'elle
vous touchiez 150000 euros par mois ce
qu'il faut dans ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est maintenant mais ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est là je reçois des tweets de
partout ça a duré une décennie
quan a lancé un dc10 à s'en [ __ ] plein
les poches et on lui a proposé
je vais vous dire c'est qu'en fait à
l'époque il y avait vous rappelez pas
mais avant le jt même de 20 heures pour
le stimuler
il y avait des séquences de vidéo gag
donc on a beaucoup tourné là dessus
c'était devenu une quotidienne plus tous
les week-end le samedi et le dimanche
ah ouais t il en a chié le montueux mais
c'est évident simon tcc du 6 7 millions
il a fait tellement de lancement 40 f1
j'avais j'avais j'avais trois quatre
émissions qui a buzzé toute très bien
mais c'est vrai sur les fêtes c'est un
empire je suis sous l'effet fait alors
là et chez vous je vous invite à parler
maintenant de lempire montiel
mais c'est loupé routière et spa rue
bernard
en tout cas bravo parce que vous dites
les choses c'est pour ça que saïda mais
c'est vrai c'est pour ça que j'étais
viré au cent cinquante mille euros et
ben est pendant des comptes bernard
montiel et gagner cent cinquante mille
euros
et quand tu gagnes 150000 euros à
envoyer des chiens qui pètent dans ce
soit en mer des affaires unis et a
défoncé tâche n interviews et il a livré
lui-même ami c'est un coup dur il sait
rien faire à part lire un prompteur le
long devra donc c'est passé c'était ça
j'avais proposé une émission de cinéma
pour sortir un peu de l'image vidéo gars
qui étaient quand même très
superficielle très légère que j'aimais
bien et maintenant je suis content et
c'était bien payé comme gelée soulignait
est en fête des menhirs
oui merci oui et en fait l'émission que
j'ai proposé le concept que j'ai proposé
ils me l'ont piqué il en donne à
quelqu'un d'autre
donc ils m'ont pris tes pas l'émission
c'est quoi c'est même un cinéma avec des
sacs des acteurs qui pète de toute
[Rires]
émission de cinéma et en fait j'ai été
profondément blessé
moi on m'a parlé de famille de machin
donc je me suis dit comme moi me tiens
pas pas l'argent je suis un homme libre
les envoyer chier j'ai eu grand plaisir
j'ai jamais regretté non malgré tout et
spector ce que moi j'adore ça qui sport
vous imaginez on est dans les temps
quelle année satis et 2003 il l'a donné
à la fila blond la hâte à yako
on est chez vote bernard montiel bernard
montiel
on est en 2003 si vous nous rejoignez
sur ces 8 bonsoir c'est une nouvelle
enquête
c'est pas une enquête c'est gai réalité
mais en amont tiennent à nîmes vidéo gag
il anime plusieurs émissions dont la une
est à vous le samedi oui oui nous
faisait croire qu'on faisait choisir des
séries alors qui les prépare à la zone
raconté l'émission cette année lucio
fanti tout était détruit qu'est ce que
vous voulez voir l' agence tous risques
ou bien vous voulez voir à dallas ou
truc mais ils savaient très bien ce
qu'ils aient des nouvelles c'était
pipeau djombo donc voilà bon donc
bernard montiel y gagne écoutez bien si
vous nous rejoignez 150000 euros par
mois cent cinquante mille euros par mois
de quoi acheter plus d'une franchise de
point soleil
oui hélas bernard montiel il y tient
j'aurais de faire un coup d'éclat life
et des interviews c'était pourquoi
l'inter nous c'était chez morandini qui
à l'époque était sur rmc voilà donc
l'agent marc moreau ligne invite
gentiment oui non c'est moi qui la paix
je voulais être invitée pour valence et
reçoit de la vie je te paye 150000 euros
va très bien et dit tiens je vais aller
balancer souvent s en tiendrait alors
narc tu peux vous promettre au défi de
me suicider donc la ja marveaux reçoit
oui là c'est pourquoi les phrases chocs
je lui ai dit j'ai dit à jean marc j'ai
déjà marre tu peux y aller n'ai pas peur
il me dit tu es sûr parce que là tu
commence bien et ne te vois bien remonté
généralement vas-y vas-y vas-y on
appelle jean marc du coup alors alors
alors oui waouh peuple et jean-marc
après alors est donc un et ben alors
j'ai balancé exactement ce que je
pensais j'ai déjà fait des quoi je suis
hyper bas et j'ai dit qu arthur il sait
pas lire un prompteur que
bon je racontais des choses de coulisses
à l'époque mais je veux pas les évoquer
maintenant puisque lieu d'être
est-ce que tu regrette d'avoir dit ça
mais j'ai jamais regretté j'étais dans
une mer de noir parce que tu sais quand
tu as l'habitude de gagner beaucoup
d'argent ne t'as plus rien du tout
vraiment une mère de noir grave et et
heureusement il ya six mois après il ya
un monsieur qui s'appelle gérald brice
viret qui était patron de télé
monte-carlo qui est allée qui est
maintenant pas con de calais attend
patron de canal + lèvres et qui me
disent tu vois je regrette pas de
l'avoir pris 150 balles par mois c'est
pas faux lombard qui devait gêner quand
même jean marc était gêné il a été très
correct qui me dit bernard tease sur la
patinoire et j'ai dit non non non non on
y va on y va
je vais quand même me rétablir la vérité
ça pas 150000 euros d'accord c'est si
vous laissez télé qui valent ans parce
que c'était à l'époque en france
justement de réaliser parce que le franc
s'est passée la cambre 2003 et mis en
mai 2011 158 en 2001 kg a pas l'air
clair tout ça non non c'est dans l'est
alors en euros ça doit faire 80000 euros
par mois c'est énorme 4 4 millions et
moi c'est donc c'était deux mois deux
mois donc c'est de moi ou pas il compte
par ce trio allemand dans un instant les
chéris oui moi au moins j'ai demandé à
bernard au bout de combien de temps tu
as eu un appel de tf1 suite à la
diffusion de l'émission
trois jours après parce qu'en fait tout
le monde était content pour handicapés
sur tf1 tous les journaux en ont fait
des choux gras
tout le monde est ravi de taper sur tf1
chaîne privée cette compagnie est
vraiment ça a été très dur comme période
j'ai perdu ma voix les 6 à l'issue de sa
vraiment totalement perdu ces pertes
soient les chocs ma voie entièrement
quand on parlait plus mais plus du tout
il n'y a pas un son qui sont restés
bloqués elle est activement ses violons
vous ont pas pris sur france 3 sur zorro
avec bernardo ça a été extrêmement
violent au fond c'était un truc très
important pour ce s'est passé quelqu'un
vous avez cités mais sale année pour
convier une sale année c'était l'année
de la perte de mon père donne un chien
de plein de choses très graves très
importante pour moi à verdun c'est une
salle andré je comprends et du coup j'ai
balayé je voulais faire une nouvelle vie
tu aurais jamais regretter mais c'était
très dur vous avez les repères
marseillais michael comme quoi et pas
toujours possible vaut mieux être libre
vaut mieux qu libre que riche
exactement
thibault
[Rires]